so guys a lot of times I hear about the
gender pay Gap and I was actually having
a conversation with someone this weekend
and it was a feminist of course talking
about oh I'm so oppressed my life is so
hard there's all these reasons women are
not paid as much and I'll say this women
are not paid as much because they're
lazy they don't want to do the hard jobs
and they love to [__] and moan even
though they do less work women want a
work life balance which is totally fine
but what comes with a work life balance
is less pay women love to take vacations
women love to spend money they don't
have and then cry about it later women
are terrible at negotiating and women
tend to have easier jobs so there was a
woman that was on TV that found out live
on air that she was not being paid and
the men were let's pull it up I'm sorry
you're so ex to be paid to go on air in
I'm that is the moment that that woman
realizes that that man has been paid
£200 want to go on TV and debate her and
she has not been paid anything to debate
him and the entire debate was sparked by
the Lawrence Fox incident which was
sparked by an argument over the gender
pay Gap and he's like so adamant that
she have been paid he's just like oh I'm
so sorry that you're so exhausted being
paid to come on TV and debate people and
she's like I'm not being paid are you
being paid I have never seen the
foundations of a debate justify the need
for the debate in that way on please go
watch that entire video it's just
ridiculous it's funny because her gut
reaction the feminist gut reaction is
that they must be paid differently
because of gender but maybe it's because
you're just Dumber maybe you don't offer
as good of commentary maybe you're not
as well known there are many reasons why
one person gets paid and another doesn't
as someone that runs a show that
actually thinks these things through I
might know that person a will bring me
me 10,000 viewers and person B will
bring me 2,000 viewers there are some
people that get more value just by
coming on the show than the show gets
from them and what modern women do is
they [__] and they cry and they moan
later instead of just negotiating better
and working harder women wanted to be in
a man's world so I say be in it be in it
and fight for your pay and if you're not
going to do that please do not [__] cry
and moan about being on TV you are a
commentator being being a commentator is
one of the best jobs on the planet I
love being a commentator it is much
easier than say a plumber a trucker or a
factory worker and so many times women
are entitled to more and more pay even
though they have a significant advantage
in the space it is much easier to blow
up as a commentator as a woman than as a
man the men typically have to work their
whole lives to get to a point where the
women are typically given that upfront I
don't make the rules I just tell you
what they are look at the daily wire for
example the younger people Brett Cooper
Candace Owens they're both phenomenal
they're both amazing commentators but to
act like they had to do as much work as
say Ben Shapiro Andrew claven and Matt
Walsh is just it's lunacy it's absolute
lunacy and it's okay we all have our
strengths and weaknesses that's okay I'm
not hating on anybody for it but what I
am hating on is women that are given in
advance in a field and then you're going
to cry about it later quit crying and
maybe just learn to negotiate better so
the comments section immediately rushed
to simpery why are Sky News paying the
men and not the women maybe because
she's not as good maybe she doesn't
offer as much
value um Taran girl says yeah I just saw
this absolutely enraging um and I just
saw this too and I want to say to shut
the [__] up oh my God Jesus Christ stop
crying I'm so tired of the bitching and
crying um user 381 18887 says this is
why I cannot tolerate anybody who says
the gender pay Gap is a myth well I'm
that Gil the gender pay Gap is
absolutely a myth quit crying and
whining about it one phenomenon that
there is is the fake wives modern women
are fake wives these are women that have
the title of a wife that maybe have been
married but do not have the mind of a
wife now the number one mindset of a
wife is nothing to do with looks it's
nothing to do with fashion it actually
has everything to do with
selflessness now I talk a lot about
Botox lip
filler hair extensions and Nails there's
nothing wrong with these things by
themselves however typically the
husbands are not the ones pushing this
on their wives the women are pushing
this on themselves in order to get more
attention from other men and not their
husbands now typically in the times of
old maybe the women would have a shorter
skirt and maybe show their ankles or
maybe slightly more revealing clothing
while they were searching and trying to
attract a husband but they knew once
they got married you were expected to
dress and act differently no you are not
expected to act the exact same way
before you get married and after you get
married once you are a married woman you
were expected to not put yourself in
certain situations and not appear as if
you are looking or appear to be
attracting attention for other men your
family's honor is very important but
modern women do not care and I'm seeing
this phenomenon of women trying to get
attention from other men in their
50s the second half of your life isn't
supposed to be about sex let's say on
average we live to be
80 when is it time to put your sexuality
away when is it time to focus more on
your
character than your looks because at a
certain point for everybody looks fade
and I asked this question because I saw
a picture of JLo let's pull it up now
JLo is a beautiful woman um she is
stunning and she is known across the
world for her looks but I asked the
question is this
how a wife and a mother should be
dressing her boobs are out she's in a
skintight dress and you know at least
younger women you can kind of Chuck it
okay they're young they're naive but
this woman has lived half of a decade
and yet she's still dressing like a a
hooker when is it time to put your
sexuality away so I asked the question
will modern women ever put their
sexuality away this is a mother and a
wife is she still married I I don't even
know women of the past understood that
over a certain age roughly 30 it was
time to dress more modestly why do
modern women feel the need to lead with
their sexuality even in their 50s I I'm
seeing this phenomenon of mothers and
wives it's Halloween time walking around
with their children dressed like skanks
with their kids what example are you
leading for your children
you know JLo has a daughter and would
she want her daughter to be dressed the
way that she dresses so another woman
that I've sort of briefly followed for a
couple years is actually Haley Bieber
and I actually thought it was like
amazing I thought it was literally
amazing that Haley Bieber could be
married to a world-renowned superstar
and she still dresses like a hooker like
on her Instagram there's all of these
pictures of her in underwear and I I
always hear the push back I hear the
push back while she was a model and my
question
is will you give up anything to be with
a world-renowned superstar now this is
also on Justin now Justin Bieber doesn't
really appear to me to be the head of
the household and his own family because
he allows his woman to dress like this
and these are the people you know that
were prating around
Christianity so this is Haley
Bieber's um Halloween costume this year
and again I beg the question she's
absolutely beautiful she's stunning she
looks awesome but she's a married woman
is this the image you want to portray of
yourself as a married
woman and again this is why I say there
are many women that look like wives they
may even dress like wives sometimes
obviously not here um but they don't
actually play the part they actually
don't go into that role and you know I
wish them the best but I I just think
that dressing this way is inviting
problems into your relationship you know
and this is a woman married to a
world-renowned
superstar I mean how how can you get
better everybody loved Justin Bieber
back in the day okay so lastly today
guys I wanted to touch on a clip that I
thought was actually hilarious um Joe
Rogan reacting to 24 things that nobody
is better than than Donald Trump let's
pull it up 24 nobody is better at than
Trump nobody can do it like me nobody
nobody can do it like me honestly
nobody's stronger than me nobody has
better toys than I do there's nobody
bigger or better at the military than I
am nobody loves the Bible more than I do
nobody builds walls better than me
nobody's better to people with
disabilities in me nobody's fighting for
the veterans like I'm fighting for the
veterans there's nobody that's done so
much for equality as I have there's
nobody more pro Israel than I am there's
nobody more conservative than me there
is nobody that respects Wom women more
than I do nobody would be
tougher you know Trump is the ultimate
picture of confident it is so hilarious
it is so funny really and truly I think
that's what got him elected is he is
really an Entertainer um and a lot of
people have asked what my opinions are
on the election um I don't follow it as
closely as some people do but right now
I am team Trump I could be persuaded in
other directions but I really when
I really think that Trump was the best
president in my
lifetime um so it'll be interesting to
see if anyone can really go head-to-head
with him I don't see any of the
Republicans doing it but and it'll be
interesting to see if Biden is actually
the one who runs I really think they're
going to find a different candidate but
you know only time will tell okay so
lastly guys every Pearl daily we read a
top comment from the last video so guys
make sure you leave a comment and like
your favorite comment below so crunchy
man 5330 says tradcons be like just be
in the top .1% of men and choose the
right woman it's just that simple okay
guys leave a comment below and I will
read the top one next time like the
video on your way out and I'll talk to
you later